we were living off our vehicles in the
desert for weeks and once out of time
we were fighting Yugi on a daily basis
rifle fire shooting being put in
stressful situations ambushes chaos the
smell of blood
pazzo vaccean people pretty badly messed
up young lads being killed
carrying casualties through mortar
attacks snipers target in me no amount
of training could have prepared me you
have to tell yourself to get on with it
you have to adapt so quickly to that
situation survival where no means of
escaping it
[Music]
[Music]
looking back when you first come back
from tour you don't even realize that
you've changed
I was just Restless I lost interest in
everything that I used to do I wouldn't
feel comfortable well in public I had
very little patience for people not a
lot of empathy you don't really feel
like you fit in anywhere you're in that
limbo I'm not military but I'm
definitely not a civilian where do I go
from here
actually I've quite often found myself
going out walking in the countryside
going into the kind of mode that I would
be on on patrol like a check-in
everything and even not carrying weight
having ruck sacks on and stuff it's feel
normal I remember finding myself looking
in gardens I'm behind wheelie bins on
the way to the chip shop to look for
weapons in case I got a tote I didn't
quite understand what was happening I
just felt quite angry and quite
depressed all at the same time as it is
a mixture of emotions and my body just
didn't really know how to deal with it
and that's when it starts to hit you
nightmares flashbacks
fear chaos
Green
anger
shame
sadness right Oh silence breaking point
post-traumatic stress disorder affects
me every day it's an invisible wound
which you can't see it's it's damage
done to the brain it's an invisible
enemy you can't fight that that six
months keeps coming back and taking over
you can't move on I was a very great
advocate of PTSD is nothing to be
ashamed of and it can happen to anybody
and you should get help when it happened
to me I didn't go and get help I felt
very very ashamed and I ignored it it
took about two or three years I should
start realizing that it was PTSD yeah I
never even considered it I still thought
there's impossible to happen smile at me
I look back now and I I can't I can't
believe that I didn't realize it's quite
a hard thing to do
picking up the phone especially for a
soldier because you're not trained to
ask for help
really every allottee the only real
treatment that there is is combat stress
there are a few other organizations but
they just not are well known I'm not a
well-funded
when you get seen and assess
and they say yes it's PTSD it's a bit of
a weight off your shoulders because you
know there's something wrong with you
you know what it is there's so many
different things that you can be treated
with now medication talking therapies
CBT light therapies they had art therapy
sessions there and that was that was
quite well like a downburst it really
it's like having a snapshot of a problem
that just goes over and over in your
head the whirlwind of stuff that's
helped me kind of go back rediscover
what I was before all this happened I am
now I level where I could sort of manage
everything my temper my depression
everything so sustainable you learn to
manage it he learns to maintain it
doesn't go away so it's it's just
learning to live with it and it takes me
onto my dog you know that's my coping
mechanism of such just a big ball of
lovely stupidness it's crazy
doesn't matter how angry you are as soon
as I see him it's just making happy
these are brilliant
everything around me is is a coping
strategy that could be a place I go to
where I sit what I listen to anything
that can distract your mind from what
it's trying to do is is a brilliant
thing I've taken up photography since I
left the army looking at the world
through a lens it's an easy way of
immersing yourself back into normality
while still retaining
a safety blanket that means the world
I've started thinking that there is life
beyond PTSD you can get your life back
you're not a write-off I think and I
think that that's often what people
think building a family and a life turn
things around a lot feeling off I've got
purpose it's taken me a long time to get
back to where I want to be and I'm
getting there yeah I've got a dark past
but I've also got a future as well PTSD
czar wound but it's not who I am I'm
going to enjoy life again